hi there steve here uh i've now
completed a week of turkish i want to
talk a bit about my experience my first
week with turkish
as part of a sort of a description of
how i see the language learning
process all right i've used various
metaphors in the past i've referred to
the uh the idea of language learning as
sort of a snowball that the more words
you pick up the more words you can
acquire that certainly becomes true
in that second stage i've talked about
three stages the first stage where we
struggle to get a sense of this strange
language which is just noise where we
it's no longer strange it becomes a
little bit familiar to us that's the
first stage the second stage where we
start to accumulate more and more words
until we get comfortable in the language
then the third stage is once we are
totally able to enjoy the language we
still make mistakes we still have things
we don't understand but we are enjoying
genuinely interesting content movies
whatever discussions and we are
continuing to infinity in terms of
trying to improve as much as we can in
the language so i'm very much at the
first stage so if i look at my first
week of activity and and remember again
that the key thing in language learning
is activity it's it's interacting with
the language don't worry about what you
achieve don't worry about what you
remember just make sure you engage with
the language so that's what i've been
doing
so if i look at my statistics at link
for example for the past week i think
i'm up to over 500 known words
i have saved i think two and a half
thousand links
and of those i have learned some 350 of
them so that the remaining links that i
created are still yellow links on my
lesson page because i have i keep on
seeing them in
new stories but i don't yet feel that i
know them i feel i know 500 of which 350
were learned presumably the other 200
were picked up because they were similar
to other words or they were words that
came from another language
french or english or arabic or persian
and i felt that i knew them without
having to look them up
i have read i think 25 000 words
sometimes reading the same lesson twice
but it's all reading so i have been very
active i had one very active day
two days ago where i have where i
created a thousand links i have read the
first 53 stories
in the mini
mini story series
but if i look at these on my lesson page
the early stories are largely white or
pale yellow as these words are gradually
becoming known
the more recent stories are
that i have read are full of
dark yellow words and phrases that i
have
saved that i have looked up but that i
don't yet know and as i progress into
new stories it'll be very heavy to blue
30 40 50
of the words in the news stories will be
stories that i haven't yet met on link
so that that the the jigsaw puzzle and
so far as the first five six seven
stories uh is concerned
are concerned there the jigsaw puzzle is
starting to show me some shape because
once the page is white that means that
in my mind these words
are clear
now
the next stage of course is to get to
where i can listen to these stories and
understand them and of course i'm not
yet there so i can read stories story 10
story 15 i understand it i can listen
and read i can go through listening
sentence by sentence and reading it and
understanding it
listening while reading but when i go
off and listen
without the help of the text i have
trouble understanding it so that's kind
of my process after one week of turkish
on link that's sort of the level of
activity i have exposed myself to the
language
i don't understand that well but i
understand when i read now one thing
about the language learning process it's
very much a matter of doing some of this
and some of that going forward coming
back and i mention that because
you know it's it's good to vary things
like if i have a very heavy day where i
saved a thousand links and i plowed
forward into 10 or 15 news stories
the next day i'm a little tired of doing
that so to vary things
i have a book
okay complete
turkish it has audio i can't listen to
the audio because it's full of english
you know
john and mary go to the grocer and order
bread and great long explanation in
english of the story i don't like
listening to that because i like
listening to the target language many
times so i can't listen to that stuff
but it is interesting because they start
to introduce for example
verbs
and
whatever they say about the verbs
are things that i have already
experienced so there is no
urgency to introduce verbs or anything
at any particular time you can always go
back to it similarly with basic
greetings i'm not necessarily very good
at saying hello how are you in turkish
and in this book they introduced very
early going to the store to buy bread or
olives and stuff like that
i haven't necessarily come across these
words in my many stories however
with the intensive exposure that i have
had to the turkish language through what
i have done in the first week when i go
into this book and i look up or i read
their explanation about how verbs work
or how cases work
uh or how to say hello how are you good
evening good morning it becomes a lot
easier for me because i have had this
exposure through my
activities at link so the point i want
to make is that language learning to me
the process is not one of building
blocks you learn this and once you have
that you learn the next step and the
next step it's more a matter of exposing
yourself to a lot of different elements
in the language constantly being able to
go back and review things that you have
forgotten or things that might be
considered basic but when they are first
introduced you can't you aren't yet in a
position to absorb them but if you have
simply allowed yourself like when i plow
into the new stories where there are a
lot of new and unknown words i kind of
feel as if i'm cross-country skiing and
i'm
and let's say i'm going around this
track twice so the first time i'm
actually having to create the track
because the snow is deep and i'm skiing
and creating a track but the second time
i come through there i already have a
track and i'm going more
easily more smoothly so
this is it you have to kind of go around
the track many many times picking up
different things each time maybe if i'm
going through the forest i'll notice a
different tree each time and that is the
process so i don't know if i make any
sense but i just wanted to stress the
fact that the key
aspect of language learning is to be
active to interact with the language to
push yourself to explore and you can
always go back later and pick up other
bits and pieces when you are motivated
to do so thanks for listening bye for
now
you